comenzamos reporteros de france 24
gracias por estar con nosotros una vez
más
hace 4 años en colombia la guerrilla de
las farc firmó un histórico acuerdo de
paz con el estado para ponerle fin a más
de medio siglo de conflicto armado la
guerrilla de ideología marxista entregó
las armas y se comprometió a seguir con
su programa como movimiento político el
acuerdo tiene objetivos de
transformación profundos pero ese anhelo
de paz parece aún lejano en un clima de
violencia y de inseguridad nos acompaña
pascal mariani corresponsal en colombia
de france 24 para la cadena en francés
pascal este acuerdo de paz que dio una
esperanza al mundo de que los conflictos
pueden resolverse a través del diálogo
siguen en la lucha por ponerse en marcha
encontró usted obstáculos en esta
implementación
pero un consejo para entender este
proceso de paz un poco mejor decidimos
seguir a algunos ex combatientes
específicamente en bogotá
muchos de estos seis guerrilleros de las
farc han cambiado sus vidas de manera
dramática y hay más de 1000 y viviendo
en bogotá con sus familias de ex
combatientes viviendo en todo el país
algunos quedaron a la deriva en las
selvas de cemento esta vez y tienen que
encontrar maneras de vivir en una
sociedad que no los acepta totalmente
electric a tus invitados entonces a ver
el reportaje de pascal mariani y juan
orosco
[Música]
esta hoja de papel contiene una disculpa
histórica a principios de la década del
2000 la carretera que une bogotá con los
llanos orientales fue el escenario de
las pescas milagrosas los secuestros
masivos realizados por la guerrilla de
las farc
que ese tipo de acciones no
correspondían al accionar de una
guerrilla revolucionaria porque no podía
una guerrilla entrar a parar una
carretera y
llevarse detenido secuestrado a
cualquier ciudadano porque tuviera una
marca de ropa o de un vehículo
cuando te encuentras a una persona que
se encuentra a una familia se causa
mucho dolor
hay enemigos de la paz probablemente
pero yo les digo a ustedes que ha tenido
toda la voluntad para llegar en la
voluntad desde la firma del acuerdo de
paz en 2016 la ex guerrilla de las farc
organiza regularmente actos de perdón en
presencia de sus víctimas a nombre de
todos los comparecientes de las extintas
farc
pedimos perdón al país
pedimos perdón a todas las personas y
familias que sufrieron en la práctica
del secuestro
fueron acciones injustificables
no hay forma de explicarla
en 2017 13.000 combatientes de las farc
que dejaron las armas
[Música]
durante dos años el país vivió una
relativa paz hasta que de nuevo surgió
la violencia
los exguerrilleros acusan al presidente
iván duque de no respetar el acuerdo
firmado por juan manuel santos- su
predecesor
[Música]
el acuerdo tiene seis puntos que son de
carácter integral reforma integral
reforma política nada de eso se ha hecho
restitución de cultivo de uso ilícito no
se están haciendo lo único que se está
medio desarrollando es lo que tiene que
ver con la reincorporación de los
excombatientes y no están asignando más
de 250 ex combatientes han sido
asesinados desde la firma del acuerdo el
crimen de albeiro suárez baleado en su
plantación de cacao desencadenó esta
movilización no tenemos claridad todavía
quiénes fueron los responsables
seguimos seguridad para los diamantes de
paz
más de 1000 antiguos miembros de las
farc que hicieron su vida en la capital
josé zamora alias chucho fue uno de los
jefes de las milicias urbanas desde las
montañas comandaba a los guerrilleros
que operaban clandestinamente en bogotá
dos guardaespaldas un ex guerrillero y
un policía lo acompañan en todo momento
alcanzamos ese fin último que era la
toma del poder pero todavía estamos en
proceso de construirlo con la gente con
las masas ahora con nuestros hijos que
eso es una de las experiencias más
hermosas poder caminar por estos
espacios con ellos a pesar de del miedo
que nos genera porque pues nos están
matando
los manifestantes llegaron ante el
congreso y el palacio presidencial para
exigir más protección y la aplicación
del acuerdo de paz
en todo el país aumentaron además los
asesinatos de líderes sociales y
defensores de derechos humanos
[Aplausos]
no se trata de una lucha partidista sino
en la lucha de la nación por lograr que
por fin podamos pasar las páginas
dolorosas de la historia de violencia
como resultado de los acuerdos de paz el
partido creado por las farc que tiene
derecho a 10 curules en el parlamento
pero ahora el movimiento político de los
antiguos guerrilleros está dividido
mucho y su pareja también ex combatiente
se conocieron en la cárcel hay muchos
compañeros que han vuelto a las armas yo
no aspiro volver me espero volver porque
tengo muchas cosas que construir aquí
gracia entre eso ese gran amor conmigo
pero no me obligue
hoy en colombia la paz es frágil
en septiembre de 2016 las farc organizan
su última conferencia en armas
por primera vez desde 1964 esta reunión
nacional de la guerrilla no es secreta
los comandantes aparecen públicamente
cuánta gente vino liberada iván márquez
dirigió el equipo negociador de las farc
durante los diálogos de la habana
ese día el gobierno libera un grupo de
combatientes encarcelados entre ellos
mucho de camiseta azul
había sido capturado ocho años atrás en
medio de un enfrentamiento con el
ejército durante esta conferencia las
farc deciden abandonar la lucha armada
sangre matando entre nosotros mismos hay
que construir países entre todos por eso
le decimos que ahora no lo permitan
reconocemos toda la disposición los
guerrilleros celebran como nunca antes
el fin de su guerra
[Aplausos]
en los meses siguientes dejarán las
selvas para dirigirse a una de las 23
zonas de desarme donde siete mil fusiles
serán depositados
este prolongado conflicto marcó
profundamente a la sociedad colombiana
en el cementerio central de bogotá se
levanta el centro de memoria paz y
reconciliación en homenaje a las
víctimas la artista beatriz gonzález
pintó miles de cuerpos anónimos en los
columbarios
en 8 millones de víctimas de los cuales
7 millones son desplazados campesinos
desplazados
pero muertes están rondando por los
300.000
este es el resultado de una guerra de
medio siglo a la que humberto de la
calle quiso poner fin de 2012 a 2016
dirigió la delegación del gobierno de
juan manuel santos en las negociaciones
el acuerdo de paz se enfrenta a la
oposición de un importante sector
político pero es un poco
paradójico por donde uno se mueve en la
comunidad mundial hay admiración por el
acuerdo por las innovaciones pero en
2018 iván duque fue elegido a la cabeza
del estado es miembro del partido del
expresidente álvaro uribe enemigo del
acuerdo y de cualquier concesión con las
farc durante la campaña la promesa era
destruir el acuerdo después comenzó hay
que reconocer una fase de implementación
del acuerdo pero me parece que los temas
más estructurales del acuerdo que son
una especie de hoja de ruta para
colombia están en el congelador el
partido de gobierno se opone a la
jurisdicción especial de paz nacido del
acuerdo este sistema de justicia
transicional busca la verdad histórica a
cambio de una cierta impunidad la clave
de la jurisdicción es convocar a todos
los victimarios farc militares que
incumplieron sus deberes y los terceros
no combatientes que financiaron la
confrontación y eso ha generado
resistencias contactamos al partido
presidencial para reunirnos con uno de
sus representantes
nuestras peticiones se quedaron sin
respuesta
el proceso de paz evoluciona en este
ambiente polarizado con el
acompañamiento de una misión de naciones
unidas
el principal premio que tiene
actualmente en la implementación de paz
sin duda gana de la tienda de seguridad
el gobierno defiende su voluntad de
implementar el acuerdo
tenemos que seguir trabajando en un
proyecto de más de 15 años que va a
involucrar más de ese gobierno pero
mensaje clave el compromiso señor
presidente y bando que con la política
de reincorporación con la implementación
de la política de paz con legalidad pero
también compromiso firme con la
seguridad según las autoridades un gran
número de asesinatos de ex combatientes
serían perpetrados por grupos disidentes
las farc acusan a agentes estatales y
paramilitares la mayoría de estos
crímenes siguen sin resolverse
los más expuestos tienen derecho a un
carro blindado
cada firmante de la paz se recibe un
subsidio de 2.400 dólares para montar un
proyecto productivo chuchos se asoció
con nueve de sus antiguos compañeros de
armas
queríamos hacer algo orgánico o algo
artesanal en un primer momento
pensábamos en hacer jabones escobas eso
pasamos por un sin número y unos
compañeros unos muchachos civiles de
guate nos enseñó la ciencia por es
artesanal bautizaron su cerveza negra la
trocha la marca se inspira en su pasado
en las montañas el objetivo es generar
empleo para los excombatientes para
ellos es difícil encontrar un lugar en
el mercado laboral como carajos yo
justificó por ejemplo que hice durante
30 años de mi vida que estuve en frentes
voy a poner una hoja de vida y me
diciendo este 30 años que hizo que digo
esto de la guerrilla
la pandemia de kobe 19 frenó su
lanzamiento comercial
la mayoría de las ventas se hacen a
domicilio
y acaban de enterarse de que pronto
tendrán que dejar su sede
en la casa todavía está en venta y ellos
nos dijeron que ya la habían vendido y
es mentira entonces es una forma
disimulada de sacarnos así como los
bancos los bancos no te dicen no les
abrimos cuentas a ustedes los
excombatientes pero nos ponen tantas
talanqueras que están seguros que no
vamos a ser capaces de cumplir lo
lanzaron en internet una campaña
solidaria para recaudar fondos
volvieron 3
se quedaron siete botellas
en una economía en crisis el regreso a
la vida civil es más complejo de lo que
habían imaginado obviamente eso
incentiva
al desespero por la no reincorporación
efectiva ser todo en lo económico y lo
social de los excombatientes pues si eso
es un caldo de cultivo perfecto para que
la gente justifique su vida nuevamente a
la clandestinidad a las armas eso
de 2000 a 3000 exguerrilleros habrían
retomado las armas
manifiesto en agosto de 2019 iván
márquez anunció el regreso de las farc
es la continuación de la lucha
guerrillera en respuesta a la traición
del estado a los acuerdos de paz de la
habana la historia parece repetirse
guerrillas paramilitares y
narcotraficantes se disputan de nuevo el
control del territorio
en bogotá los excombatientes organizan
un desfile de ropa confeccionada por
ellos mismos
una feria muestra los productos
artesanales de sus distintas
cooperativas
pues ahí estamos viviendo contra la
corriente haciendo resistencia al
capitalismo la mayoría de los
excombatientes sienten nostalgia de la
vida en la guerrilla
[Música]
muchos siguen creyendo en esta paz
incierta
en una sociedad que aún no los ha
perdonado del todo
[Música]
regresamos con pascal mariani autora del
reportaje que ustedes acaban de ver y le
pregunto si este acuerdo de paz fracasa
quién va a tener la mayor
responsabilidad
[Música]
bueno sin lugar a dudas los líderes del
partido político del expresidente álvaro
uribe vélez son los principales enemigos
de este proceso ellos mismos lo dicen
ellos mantienen la oposición a cualquier
concesión hacia las farc y muchos
colombianos los apoyan y también son el
partido gobernante el presidente viene
de sus filas y lo que hace
extremadamente difícil en aplicar un
proceso de paz cuando el gobierno actual
se opone a la idea misma ya las reformas
socio políticas que son la base del
acuerdo hicieron dif humo de 7 com mi
cumple tu delay caylus seis incluso
humberto de la calle jefe de
negociaciones en la iniciativa de paz
del gobierno y dice estar molesto con
los ex combatientes de farc se dice que
se siente traicionado por los
guerrilleros que han retomado las armas
you wish you were here islam sir kent
demond y pet markets y ese es el caso
puntual de iván marketing jesús santrich
que eran líderes importantes de las farc
en el caso de sant trick fue acusado de
narcotráfico desde que volvió al combate
luego una investigación parlamentaria
determinó que fue un montaje deliberado
para desestabilizar el acuerdo
desde entonces santrich y márquez
volvieron
algo que pasa constantemente en colombia
es como una novela pero en este caso es
una novela trágica porque el país de
nuevo se encuentra envuelto en una
guerra civil ahora qué
el acrónimo farc significaba fuerzas
armadas revolucionarias de colombia
después de la firma del acuerdo de paz
el grupo tomó el nombre de fuerza
alternativa revolucionaria del común
como movimiento político ahora este
partido político fuck va a cambiar su
nombre cuáles son las razones pascal
el partido farc ha anunciado el cambio
de nombre por dos razones la primera es
que el acrónimo farc está asociado con
décadas de guerra y seguimiento para los
colombianos pero también porque los
grupos disidentes que retoman las armas
toman el nombre farc cuando vuelven el
empate entonces para evitar las fusiones
y para separarse de los combatientes el
partido ahora se llamará con los comunes
saben este grupo tiene puestos en el
parlamento después del acuerdo de paz lo
que les da cierta identidad políticas
esto nos dijo una senadora de farc que
nos habla desde su puesto en el
parlamento yo digo que hacemos un
diálogo serio lineal con muchos sectores
políticos por supuesto que los partidos
de gobierno especialmente el partido del
centro democrático con ellos no hay
manera de ninguna acción por el
contrario hay una estigmatización
permanente hacia nuestra labor y hacia
nuestra gente en los territorios
justificando
asesinato eso es muy doloroso y además
es un atentado contra la paz de colombia
qué se sabe de aquellos que decidieron
continuar en el combate armado
el all-star que son los nuevos
combatientes de las farc están divididos
iván márquez esperaba ser el nuevo líder
de todo el movimiento disidente pero no
lo logró entonces de muchas partes del
país se tienen dos grupos separados del
parc que responden a diferentes líderes
y que están en guerra entre sí y para
ellos son unidos forma es un 18 20 con
un bien y de acuerdo a información de
las autoridades colombianas iván market
se encuentra en venezuela protegido por
nicolás maduro lo que introduce una
dimensión regional a este regional
gracias a pascal mariano y por este
reportaje a ustedes también gracias por
acompañarnos y una vez más te recuerdo
que pueden ingresar a nuestra página web
france24 puntocom para ver esta emisión
y las anteriores hasta la próxima semana
[Música]